some people can see all your mistakes  though you hold it in your shoulders  show it your face  Louis I'm John your mother was a good  woman your grandparents they asked me if  I'd give you a lift they don't love the  idea you riding on his bus for three  days  you want drive right now keep the engine  running don't turn it off for any reason  you understand  why'd you do it why'd you bought that  place because we didn't have any money  donation  you're a liar I made a lot of mistakes  in my life but they were my mistakes  nobody else's  stay here there's a joke right looks a  little over 6,000 bucks right there  who's short fourteen thousand and change  try that's all you get John John  all those mistakes start piling up  inside you problem is there are certain  things that I just can't change about  myself but Alan respecter hardness test  killing Stephane Pavano mind philomene  this can probably make it skin awesome  if you are not idea by D where the done  fantastic esteem